foreign
is one of the emerging programming
languages and according to the most
recent figures python is the most used
coding language for about 80 percent of
developers and the syntax of this high
level programming language is simple to
understand
and pythons lives Library System makes
it a best choice for data science
machine learning and artificial
intelligence projects
so hello learners welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel and today we will
be doing photo manipulation using python
but before we begin if you love watching
Tech videos subscribe to our Channel
like the tutorial and hit the Bell icon
to now miss an update
and let us have a simple question to
brush upon our knowledge that would be a
quiz question
and your question is which one of the
following has the highest precedence in
the expression
and your options are
first option is division second is
subtraction third is par and the fourth
is parentheses
please answer in the comment section
below and we'll update the correct
answer in the print comment you can
pause the video give it a thought and
answer in the comment section and I have
an insightful for you guys
so if you're focused on building strong
Foundation skills for career growth in
that case you can check out a free
course to Learn Python Basics with a
completion certification from scale up
by simply learn and you can check this
python Basics free scale of course with
the link in the description below and
with here we'll start a tutorial and
first I will show you
the pillow Library
with which we would be doing the photo
manipulation
and in this video we will learn how to
modify and manipulate images using the
python pillow Library
so pillow Library it's a fork of the
Python Imaging library that is pil and
it allows us to do many different things
to our images such as changing the file
extension resizing the image cropping
the image changing colors of the image
blurring it and many more tasks
pillow is extremely useful when you have
multiple images you wish to process at
once for example you can use pillow to
automatically create different size
thumbnail of image you upload to your
web server
to see you could just
go to the pillow
website
this is the official website you could
see the command to install the pillow
module that is PIP install below you
could simply copy it and paste in your
command prompt and run it the pillow
module would be installed for you
and if we go to its documentation
you can see all the properties here and
the classes
that are image file module image filter
module image font module animation
module so these are all the module all
the classes that are in the pillow
Library
so we would be using some of them
and to start with
first we'll create a folder
and name it as
photo manipulation
using python
and here we will open the command prompt
and write the command code space period
this will open my ideally that is I am
using the visual studio code you could
use any ideally that you have hands on
any Jupiter notebook
spider you could use any and here we
will create the file and name it as
pick
Dot py
and to manipulate image we need an image
so for that
we can visit
a website that is freepik.com
and here
I will
do the manipulation on a mountain image
so you could just search
any keyword here
I will use this image
it will need your login you can just
login into that
and click on the download option okay it
interact with me again
and click on download and download the
free option
okay
now
we'll go to the downloads and copy that
and paste it in a same folder
so that we don't need to write the path
to the image and name it as picture
and the extension of this image is jpg
so now the first thing to start with our
project is
install the packages and import them
to install the package
we will write the command tip install
pillow and press enter
you could see that it states that the
requirement is already satisfied
that is I have already installed the
pillow Library so I don't need to
install it again
you could just write the command to
install that and if you get any error or
any mistakes
you could just comment down the video
and we will get to help you
so starting with first we'll import the
library
so first we'll write from eil
will import
image
that is the image module
we will be using image enhancer
and the image color
let's
get Capital CIA image column
so the first thing we will be doing is
opening the image that is
getting the image and after that we will
do
many manipulations with that
so first we'll create a variable and
name it as image and
here we will use the image module
and its open function
to open the image and in the inverted
comma so you pass the name of the image
else you have to pass the path where the
image is stored as it has been stored in
the same folder we will
processing with our project so here we
just need to pass the name of the image
we'll save this
and run it
so it has open the image and to get the
image displayed we will just write image
Dot
show that is the show function
we will save it and run it again
it takes time to open the image in your
default
image application so you could see the
image here
we'll close it
now you have seen how to show an image
and we have opened the image
so we'll command this
add
move to another
property that is resizing of the image
so first we will comment down the
heading that is
resizing
of the image
and here first we will create a variable
and name it as new size
and in this
we will
write the size we want for a new image
that would be 300 comma 300.
that is the width and the height of the
pixels
and now we will create another variable
that is image underscore resized
and inside it we'll use the variable
image in which we have stored at image
that is picture.jpg
and use the resize function here
and will pass the new size
that is the size we want for a new image
and here
first we will save this image so it
would be displayed here in the folder
only
for that we will use the variable
in which we have stored the image
that is image underscore resized
and save it
and inside we will pass
the resized dot jpg
that is the name with which we want to
save the image the new image which we
have resized
and we will also write a command that is
print
image underscore resized
dot size
so the size would be displayed and we
would be confirming
that we have code the resized image so
we will save this and run it
so you could see in the output that it's
showing 300 comma 300 that is the size
of the new image and inside the folder
you could see that we have the
resize.jpg
if we click on that so it's has been
resized and its size is now 300 crores
300.
now we have learned how to resize an
image now moving on
we will extract the information of a
particular image
so first we will comment this down
and write a heading
that would be
image information
and the first thing we would be
extracting would be the size of the
image for that you would simply write
print
and the size of the original image that
is the picture.jpg and it's stored in
the variable image
for that we would write image
Dot
size
and the next thing we want is the file
name
put that to write print
image Dot
file name
and the next thing we want is
the format of the image
and the next thing is the format
description
image node
format underscore description
so we'll save it
and run it
so we could see that the size is
5914 comma 3943 that is the width and
the height of the image and the second
is the file name that is pitcher.jpg and
the third is a format that is JPEG and
the fourth is the format description
that is JPEG and it has ISO 10918
now we have seen how to extract the
information for a particular image
now
if you want to see how many images with
a particular extension are stored in a
folder you could run a loop for that and
extract all the name of the files
so I will show you how to do that first
I will comment this down
and first of all write the heading for
that
that would be
get all the images
with same extension
from a folder
okay
and for that we would be requiring the
OS module
I will import it import
OS
and you need to install that module
so for that you could visit the official
website of the OS module that is
pypi.org and the OS iPhone SOS
so you could see this command that is
PIP install OS iPhone SOS you could just
simply copy this command
and paste it in your terminal
and press enter you will get this module
installed in your system
now moving back
okay
here we will run the loop
that is 4
a variable f
n
o s dot
list directory
and inside will pass period inverted
commas
semicolon and write a conditional
statement if
F ends with
foreign
jpg
then
we will
print all the files
now we'll save this and run it
you put C
that it has stated two files that is
picture.jpg and the resized.jpg
that are both the files that is present
in a folder
so now you have understood how to
extract the files with the same
extension from the folder
moving on
we'll see how to create a blank image
and to create that
first we will write the heading
create
a blank image
okay
so first we'll be creating a variable
and name it as image underscore blank
[Music]
here we will use the image class
and the new function and inside
we would write
rgba
and pass the size
for the image that is 1000 comma
600.
and after that we would get this image
shown
that would be image underscore blank
and
that is the variable in which we are
storing the new image and use the show
function to get it displayed we'll save
this and run it
you could see uh my picture application
has opened and this is the
image that is the blank image
and to get its information you could
check it we will get the size of the
image
so first we will comment this down
else it would take time to open that
application again
so we'll get
printed that is image underscore blank
dot size
and save this and run it
so you could see in the terminal that is
the output 1000 comma 600 that is the
size so you could verify that your blank
image has been created
now we'll see how to rotate an image so
first we will comment this down
and move ahead and write a heading that
would be
rotate an image
okay
so for that we will create a variable
and name it as image underscore rotate
and inside we will use the variable in
which our original image is stored that
is image and use the rotate function
and inside will pass the degrees to how
many degrees we have to rotate this
image I have passed 60
and after that I will get the image
displayed that would be image underscore
rotate that is the variable name in
which we are storing the rotated image
and use the show function to get it
displayed
and save this and run it
so it will open the application and that
is the default application in
which I open the images
so it has opened that
you could see that the images has been
rotated by 60 degrees
and you could see the corners they are
not displayed properly they are cutted
in the frame
so to get these
this plate in the frame and don't get
the corners
sloped out or cut out we would use a
property that is expand
and state it as true
so we will save this
and run it again
so it takes time to open the application
and show the image
so we'll just wait for that
the application has opened
and you could see that the image has
been rotated by 60 degrees and it has
been filled in the frame it's not out of
the frame
so there are other properties also
for rotate
as you can fill the color in the frame
that is in the background of the image
so
I will tell you how to do that
we'll use
fill color
variable and inside
we would use
image color class
on the module
and use the
get color function
and inside will pass the color we want
and the colors that are present
in any image that is RGB
red green blue
and now
I want this image to be shown that
command is here only I have saved it and
run it for you guys
so it will take time to get the
application open in which we will see
the color
you could see that the background is
filled with the red color
you could also change the color that is
we will display green color
in the background we'll save this and
run it
it takes time to open the application so
it just opened and you can see that the
background is filled with the green
color
now we have seen how to rotate an image
now we'll see how to crop an image
so we will comment this down
and
down and first we will write the heading
that is
crop and image
and here we will create a variable image
underscore group
and inside we'll use the variable in
which we have stored our original image
that is image and use the crop function
and inside will pass four parameters
that is leftex top wire right X and
bottom y I will
write those parameters
that is left
X
top y
and write X
and the bottom line
okay so we'll pass some for
this image
first I will pass 0 comma 0
comma
zero
no not zero
could be around 1500
and
1500.
so I will
save this and first get it displayed
so for that I will write
image underscore group and use the show
function
to show that
save this and run it for you guys
and you can see that it has used zero
zero and that is 1500 and
downward hits
1150
okay
I will close that and will show you the
original image
and save this
and run it again for you guys
so now I will show you
this is the original image and this is
the left X
top 5 right X and the bottom Y
coordinates
and what we have got is
that is 0 0
1500 that is the right X and one one
five zero that is the bottom y
okay
so now you have seen how to crop an
image
now we will just comment it
and now we will see how to flip an image
so for that first we will write
the heading that is
clip an image
and for that first we will create a
variable that would be image
underscore first we will flip it in
horizontal manner
horizontal
and
inside we will use the variable in which
we have stored the original image that
is image and here we will use the
transpose function
transpose
and inside we'll use the image class
and
then the trans
pause function
and now
we will write the property to flip it
from left to right so for that would
write
in capital letters flip underscore
left underscore
right okay
and now
I'm going to get this image displayed
for that will write
image
underscore horizontal that is the name
of the variable in which we have stored
the flipped image and use the show
function to get it displayed we'll save
this
and run it
you could see that the image has been
flipped I will show you
with respect to the original image that
is you could see these Rocky Mountain
and it is flipped
from left to right and it's here now
now
we will see how to flip an image in
vertical Direction
so for that
we will create a variable and name it as
image underscore vertical
and inside we will use the variable
image in which we have stored the
original image and use the transpose
function
and inside
we'll use the image class
and then
the transpose function and here we will
write the command to flip it from top to
bottom clip underscore
top underscore
button
and we will get this image displayed now
so
we'll write
its variable name that is image
underscore vertical
and save this
and run it for you guys
so as you can see that this application
to open this image it takes time
now just wait for that
or it has open this application
and you can see that the image has been
flipped
I will
open the original image
so this is the original image and this
is the flipped image
so we have flipped the image from top to
bottom
and there's another property that is
transpose only
what it does it first flip the image
from left to right and then top to
bottom
we can see that also so for that first
we'll create a variable that would be
image underscore transpose
and
here we would
use the image variable in which we have
stored our original image and the
transpose function and inside
we will use the image class
then the
plants pose function and here
the method would be transpose and that
would be in the capital letters
and we will get it displayed
suppose
not show so we'll save this and run it
for you guys
it is taking time
to open that application to show the
image
so we'll wait for that
so you could see that
we will open the original image
so first it has flipped it from left to
right and then top to water
you could see that the rookie mountains
are here so first it has flipped it from
this side and then top to bottom
now
uh there are other options also that is
rotate 90 degrees
transverse transverse would be first it
would
flip it from right to left and then
bottom to top so I will show you one
more option that would be transverse
and then we could move to another
properties
of below so we'll create a variable and
name it as
image underscore transverse
and I will use the image variable in
which we have stored the original image
that would be image
Dot
transpose function and inside
we'll call the image class
and use the transpose function
and then
we'll write
that transpose option
not transpose that would be the
transverse
transverse okay
now to get it displayed we will just
get its variable with the show function
that would be image underscore trans
verse dot show and save this
okay we have an area
trans
okay now it's correct
so we'll save this and run it
it takes time to get that application
started and display the image
so the application has started and you
could see that first it has rotated the
image
left to right
that is first we have done that left to
right and then
from
bottom to top
now first it has rotating the image
right to left and then bottom to top
okay now moving on
you will see another option and that
would be very fast I will copy this
and paste this
and we will rotate it by 90 degrees
okay options to rotate it by 90 degree
80 degree 180 degree or 270 degrees
so for that we will just replace this
with rotate
underscore 90.
okay and we'll get it displayed
and save this and run it
so it's taking time to open the
application
we'll wait for that
now the application has opened and you
could see that the image has been
rotated by 90 degrees
so you could use other options that
would be rotate 180 degree rotate 270
degree
but moving on
now we will move and now we'll see how
to
like increase the size of the image
so for that we'll write the command
increase the size that would not be the
coin that would be the heading increase
the size of the image
foreign
so first we'll create a variable and
name it as scale factor
and inside we will pass to
that means we'll just double the size of
the image
and now we'll create another value
variable and name it as new
and inside this variable
we'll use the image variable in which
our original image is stored and use the
size function
and take the value that is stored in the
zeroth index
and multiply it with this scale factor
okay and now
this is the height and now we will
multiplying the width and that is stored
in the first index
of the size image dot size
and first index that is the
width and then the height height would
be stored in the first 10 times
now we'll multiply this with scale
factor
okay
now we will create another variable and
name it as
New Image new underscore
image
and
here
we will just use the resize function to
the original image that is stored in the
image variable and
inside will pass the variable in which
we have
get the new parameters of the size
that is new
now we will display the image
it is
the new underscore image
and use the show function to display it
so I'll save this and run it
so it will take time to open the
application and get an image shown
so you could see this is the new image
and to confirm that it has double it
size we'll just write the command print
and the name of the image that is new
image
and use the show function
not so function the size function
to get the size that should be doubled
and will comment this
command so that
it doesn't take much time
we should only get the size as the
output only and that would be in the
terminal
so you could see the size that is one
one eight two eight and seven double
eight six and
the original size was
you will get the original size also
printed here so for that we will write
the command print
and inside will pass the variable name
in which we have stored our original
image that is picture.jpg
and use the size
function we'll save this and run it
so you could see that
okay
this is the original size of the image
and this is the size of the image that
we have multiplied by Factor two that we
have doubled the size of the image
so now you have understood how to
increase the size of the image
now moving on
we will use another class of the pillow
library that would be the image enhance
or the image enhance module
in which we would be
enhancing brightness
doing grayscale to the image
so first we have to import that
I have imported that
okay
so first thing we would be doing is
converting the image to grayscale in
other words we can say black and white
that is storing a grayscale image
instead of a multi-colored image and it
is more efficient and it's easier for a
machine to understand it
so for that
we will create a variable that would be
IMG
and
in that right image
dot convert
and inside we will pass
l
and we'll save this image
so we have used the save
there and we'll pass the name of the
image for
which you want to get it stored
we will name it as grayscale
dot jpg
so we'll save this and run it
you see that grayskill.jpg
has been stored here so you could see
that
the command has converted the
image into black and white that it has
applied the grayscale defect
and this is our original image
now moving on now we will add some light
to our image except click
if there are shadowed image we could add
some light that is adding brightness
with the help of the machine
so for that we'll write a command
and first
we will just comment this down
and first we will create an enhancer
here
for that we'll write a command color
underscore enhancer
and here we will use image
that is the image enhance module
and here we will use
first the brightness
and inside we will pass the name of the
variable in which we have
stored the original image
so let's find some error
okay now I will give it downwards
so here we'll create another variable
and that would be enhanced image
and here we would
name it as brightness enhancer
okay
and we'll use this variable here that
would be brightness
enhancer
and here
we'll use the enhance function
and inside we will pass to which extent
we want to enhance the brightness
so we'll just write
1.8 you could write any float values or
integer values
we have imported image enhance
okay
I'm losing it
okay so we'll save this
and run it
so we could see that we have written a
wrong spanning of the module that is
image enhance
and we have imported that in the
starting only
so now
we'll use the show function to get the
image displayed with the brightness
enhancer
we have to set the value
of the enhance here
that is I will set it as 1.8
or in starting I would set it as 6.
and now I will use
an enhanced underscore image
and use the show function to get the
image displayed
and save this and run it
so it takes time to open the application
to display the image
so we'll wait for that
we get any error
image and hands
okay I think this is the previous one so
we'll just run it again
okay it hasn't
open that and this is the image and
just don't close all the previous images
and it has opened another image that is
with the brightness and at an intensity
of 6.
so we're going to decrease the intensity
and
pass 1.8 as intensity and run it again
now
we're just waiting for the application
to open the image and after that we can
see the intensity of the brightness
that we have set at 1.8 so you can see
that the image hand has been enhanced
with the brightness
and that too with the intensity 1.8
now
we will
see the color enhancement in our
original image
over that
we will create a variable
that would be color underscore enhancer
and inside should use the module that is
image enhance
and use the color function
and inside will pass the variable in
which we have stored the original image
that is it would enhance the Vibrance of
the image
and here we will pass the intensity
and first we will change the variable in
which we want the enhancement
that is color underscore enhancer
and
we will enhance with an intensity of
5 so we'll save this
and run it
so our application takes time to open up
as I have to clear some
but I am Instagram management for my
system has not been set up properly you
could see that
the color has been announced or there's
a Vibrance here
so we have seen two options that is the
brightness and the color now we'll see
about contrast
so for that we will create a variable
that would be
contrast underscore enhancer
and here we'll use the image
enhance
Library
and use the contrast function
contrast and inside will pass the image
variable in which we have stored our
original image
and inside this enhanced image to
variable we will change the variable
name
with contrast enhancer
and we'll set the enhancement by F5 only
and to display
that image
okay that would be the same variable
only
we'll save this and run it
and after this contrast enhancement we
will do sharpness enhancement
so you could see that the contrast has
been enhanced with an intensity of 5.
now moving on we will shift to
sharpness and answer and for that we
will create a variable and name it as
sharpness underscore enhancer
and use the image enhance module
and its function that is sharpness
and inside we will pass the variable
that would be image in which we have
stored our original image
and in a in this variable that is
enhanced image we will replace this
contrast enhance our variable with
sharpness and answer
and we'll enhance this
with an intensity of 6.
so we'll save this and run it
and we have the show function we need
that
is it will display the image with the
sharpness
so we're just waiting for our
application to open that image
so you could see in this image that the
sharpness has been increased if you want
to see the original image I will show
you that
so this is the original image
and this is the image with the sharpness
increased or enhanced with an intensity
of 5.
now we have seen how to enhance the
image
now we'll see
how to use filters
in our image so we'll just comment it
and we'll see some basic filters that
would be the blurb filter Contour filter
and some Edge filter
so for that
move downwards and we'll be using the
image filter module and we have to
import that
and for that we will write the command
image
Delta
and now we will start with
some of the basic filters
using
filters
in here we'll create a variable that
would be image underscore blur
and inside this
we will use the variable image in which
we have stored the original image and
then the filter function
and inside will pass
or use the image filter Library the
module
and its blur function
okay
and now we will get this image displayed
and for that we'll just
write down the variable name that is
image underscore blur and use the show
option to get our image displayed
save this and run it
you would be knowing that this
application would take time to open that
image
so we'll wait for that
so
we could see that it has blurred the
image
now if you want I can just in case it's
intensity
now we have seen how to blur the image
or how to use the filter
now we'll see some other filters that is
Contour
for that we'll create a variable image
underscore
Contour
and here we will use the variable image
in which we have stored our
original image
and after that we will use the filter
and inside we'll use the image
filter module
and the function
that is Contour
image filter
foreign
capital and now we'll
get this displayed
and use the show function for that I'll
save this and run it
so our default application that would be
displaying this image
and moving on we would be seeing some
other filters that would be the detail
filter
and
The Edge enhancement filter
so we have just used the control filter
you could see the effects of that
now moving on we will use the detail
filter so that will create a variable
that would be image underscore detail
and inside we would use the image
variable and the filter function
and inside this function we'll use image
Builder module
and then the
detail
filter
and after that we will get it displayed
just replace the name of the variable
save this and run it for you guys
so an application takes time to open
this image
now an application has started
so here
we have used the
detail function detail filter
you could see the details
now moving on
we will use other filters that is
Edge enhancement or hnns
so for that
we will create a variable that would be
image underscore
h
and here we'll use image Dot
filter and inside reduce
image
filter
module
and use the
Edge enhance filter
so
it would mean the capital letters only
and here we will change the name of the
variable with the show function
save it and run it
now we are waiting for my application to
show that image and the effects of the
filter that is it would enhance the
edges of a image
and we have one more filter that is H
enhanced mode that is output enhance the
edges of the picture at a very much
extent
so this is the filter for antennas and
now we'll see another filter
that would be
we will
change its name of the variable
and name it as
underscore more
and inside we would use image variable
and the filter function inside will
reduce image filter
module
and filter would be
underscore more
we will save this
and
okay
it will carry out
so we'll just
changed the name here
and save this and run this
and after this we'll see some other
filters that would be ambos sharp smooth
and there's one more filter that would
be smooth more
so this is the
Edge
that would be Edge enhance more
so
moving on we'll see some other filters
that is we'll start with
uh we have another filter for edges
okay this is the output for the edge
enhance mode
and close this and we have another
filter so some filters are not applied
to this particular image as if your
image has
some
particular edges it would enhance them
more with this filter
so here we would be using another filter
that would be fine edges
so for that we'll create a variable
image underscore point
and
write image.filter
and inside would pass
image filter module
and inside would pass the filter name
that is find underscore
edges
and here we'll change the name of the
variable
that is fine
and save this
and run it
till then we could get a variable for
another filter that would be embossed
foreign
pass image
filter
and the emboss
let's save this
it won't
so first one complete this emboss
[Music]
filter
so we'll save this and
run it so it would show the output for
the image underscore find variable that
is where we have used the filter that is
the find underscore edges
so it will show the
edges
in a picture
waiting for our application
to open the image
so in this you could see the edges and
to get into the technology of the edges
you could search it on the web
so like if you want to be
of
person who uses Photoshop so you would
be knowing that click
what are these terms
so now we have used the emboss filter
we will just replace it in the show
function
that is image underscore numbers we'll
save this and run it for you guys so we
will get the output for the emboss
filter
you just wait for the output
as our application is taking so much
time to get output
so this is the ambos build up
moving on we have some other filters
that is
sharp so we'll just copy the command
paste it
and
rename the variable as
image underscore sharp and inside the
filter
we'll just
pass
the filter name that is sharpen
and here in the show function we'll also
rename
that is shot
and save this
and run it
so this is our output for the
sharp filter
now we will see another filter
that is smooth
so for that we'll just
replace the variable
I've just renamed it
and we will use
the smooth filter we will save this
and we'll just
change the name here that is smooth
save it and run it
so you could see the output
that is for the smooth filter
now we will see
some rank filters
so first we will command these filters
and
for these rank filters
you will create variable that would be
image underscore Main
and that would use the image variable
and the filter
function and inside
that will use image
filter
and the main filter function
inside we will pass the size
okay sorry
I'm using the period here
size that would be equal to 5.
and
we will get it displayed
and save this and run it
so this is the
uh so this is the output for the
minimum rank filter
and with this size equal to 5.
and similarly we have other filters that
is the median and the max
for that we'll just copy the command
paste it
and rename the variable as immediate
underscore median
and inside windows filter
and here we will use
the median filter
and in the show function we'll just
replace it it would be image underscore
median dot show we will save this and
run it
foreign
that this is the output
for the median
filter so we'll close this
now we will see how to combine some
filters recommend two filters
for that first of all write the heading
that would be
combine filters
and here we will create a variable image
underscore
emboss
and here we will combine blur Plus embos
two filters and for that we'll write
image.filter
and inside your pass
image
filter
Dot
create another variable
image
underscore
members Dot
filter
that is we would be
image underscore emboss underscore blur
we are using two filters that is emboss
and blur so we'll create a variable for
blur here
that would be equal to
image
underscore emboss that is that
as the most filter now we'll use
filter here
and inside this we'll use the image
filter
Dot
chain blur
and we will give its radius
that is equal to 3.
and we'll save this image
image
underscore
glucose blur
dot save
and we'll name it as
99
.
PNG
let me change the extension also
PNG
it is emboss blur
this remorse underscore
blur
and save this and run it
you can see that 99. PNG is
saved in a folder
we will open this
and this image has two filters
inside it that is ambos and blur
so you could see this image
now with that we have come to the end of
this session
and I have an insightful for you guys
that is the python certification course
that is if you are aiming to get
certified in Python Programming and want
to build a python software development
career in that case you can check this
python certification course by simply
learn that will open the doors for the
best career opportunities and to find
the details of this python certification
course you can check its Link in the
description box below
and this could be the ideal solution to
help you build your career in the right
direction and I will also give you this
Visual Studio code file that is the dot
py file in the description box you can
download it from there and use that for
your purposes
and I hope this session was interesting
and informative if you liked it please
let us know in the comment section below
and also do subscribe to our Channel and
stay tuned for more from Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here